[Music]
tonight we have a fantastic talk for you
Patrick house has a PhD in neuroscience
from Stanford he's currently doing
postdoc work at Stanford in genetics he
has the distinction of being the only
person to have both one The New Yorker
caption contest and also written for the
magazine that bears no importance on
tonight's event but wanted to share that
with you please give a big round of
applause for Patrick so this does all
right
so titling a talk titling your talk
about the stuff that you do I find quite
difficult and I find it very similar I
was thinking about this I find it very
similar to kind of coming up with a
nickname for like your best friend in
high school and what I mean by that is
that there's a kind of like immediacy to
the first thing you decide upon there's
like an imprinting to it and it doesn't
matter what change is about the person
they could be like 40 and divorced by
now but they still get called the thing
that they were first called so this
title the case of the fearless Rhett is
a title that I used a couple years ago
and this will be the first slide in this
talk and it'll be the last slide in this
talk and what's interesting to me is
that my thinking on the topic has
changed quite a bit since I first did
this and when I get to what it is that's
changed I'll let you know but the
possible second way to title this talk
maybe a more modern version would be
something like typing into Google you
can do this now parasite makes you and
what comes up is an autocomplete for
parasite makes you like cats and so this
is this potentially could serve as an
entirely it's on a title on its own and
there is something differ
though between the first and the second
title in the first it's a rat that has
become fearless in a second it's you and
you like cats but the thing that is in
common is actually this parasites that's
in between the two and so first I want
to tell you about the parasite so the
parasite is called Toxoplasma it is a
tiny single-cell organism it is the
shape of a banana maybe like a crescent
and your canonical scale you have the
diameter of a human hair
so the parasite itself because it's
single-celled does not have legs had to
be multicellular you're either if you're
multi cell you read there are legs or
you have legs or you're a single-celled
parasite but a single cell anything
cannot itself get around other than by
this kind of type of motility that that
you see here and so these individual
parasites that move like this can get
inside of different hosts and when they
do the individual parasites will
actually glom together they'll form
these beautiful little rosette cysts as
you see here this will all make more
sense eventually so the interesting
thing though is that this parasite can
only sexually reproduce in cats so up
here is going to be the same diagram you
can refer to it at any time the explain
to once so what happens is the parasite
can only reproduce in the stomach of the
cat and afterward it has to get because
it has no means of locomoting on its own
from one cat to the next and the way
that it does that is it uses
intermediate hosts something like a
mouse something like a rat and when it
gets into this Mouse it can then
basically progress in its life cycle
perhaps it's it gets eaten by another
intermediate host but the ultimate goal
the evolutionary kind of target of this
parasite is to get back to the another
cat right so how do you do this without
legs of your own you use intermediate
hosts use something like a rat or a
mouse and when that rat or mouse gets
eaten by another cat the parasite life
cycle completes etc so the problem
though a problem is that rats and mice
are not the only host for this Paris
so it's actually really really good at
what it does and those little cysts can
survive for quite a long time in the
environment and there is a kind of
worldwide basically like epidemic of
this parasite in many many different
types of animals so these are both from
last year
last year it was found in 15% of Arctic
beluga whales and it killed for the
first time a giant panda and the Chinese
Zoo so this this parasite is pretty
nefarious in its spread off the coast of
California people otters are actually
dying it's it's killing a significant
more than half of the population of
otters off that goes to California
partly because what's happening is that
people are flushing their litter their
count litter down the toilet which is
technically illegal but it ends up in
storm drain runoff goes out into the
ocean otters can't handle it and they
end up dying so they're kind of more
this is you know tragic in its own way
but the more that kind of like
interesting intermediate host is the
human so it turns out that at least a
billion people and maybe upwards of up
to a third of the entire population of
people on this planet test positive for
this parasite have this parasite and so
what is happening is that the cat poop
so fertilizer companies by poop from any
source they can and they use it and they
use it for fertilizer for feed Lots for
grounds for for cattle cows pigs goats
etc and when these animals eat this from
the grass they get it themselves it gets
stuck in their muscle tissue there's a
study in Britain where they just went
into a random supermarket and just
bought out the place all the meats then
went back in tested at 28 percent of the
meat had talked so they went to a the
USDA in Massachusetts went to a pig farm
pigs meant for human consumption a
hundred percent of the pig's head talked
so and so it's it's killed by cooking it
but not everyone does cook it if you
have steak tartare because I'm barbecue
like not everyone there there aren't
cultures of cooking you're me everywhere
so these are kind of like
incidental hosts and this is not
actually we can't we can't learn much
about the parasite itself from these
kind of dead-end hosts but what we can
do is we can try to ask well what is it
maybe evolutionarily so evolutionary
biologists came up with this idea that
it has to get from one cat to another
cat and maybe what it's doing when it's
infecting these intermediate hosts these
mice and these rats is that it's getting
into their brain so this parasite can
get into the brain of a toast and when
it's in the brain maybe it's doing
something maybe it's like fiddling
around in there and doing something to
actually make that intermediate host
more likely to get eaten by the cat and
so this was basically my PhD figuring
out in a mouse what is different if we
give it this parasite what is different
in its brain that might make it more
likely to get eaten by a cat so what we
want to focus on though is the
individual Mouse so what this is is work
from our lab that shows an individual
Mouse with photographs taken of an
individual Mouse over time and these
photographs show the you're now already
totally familiar with the fact that up
there at the top it starts as a single
cell and over you can see in the top
left of each little panel there's like a
zero of for Nate's and said there's I
would obviously show you but for some
mystifying physics reason the light or
light pointer doesn't work well they
works here not there anyway so you have
this time course of this individual
Mouse and what the infection actually
looks like and so what you end up with
is you can see that it starts in the
body so this is a parasite that's been
genetically modified with a gene from a
jellyfish so it actually lights up in
bioluminescence in the same way that
like the ocean does occasionally when
you step into it and so these parasites
are by luminescing and you can actually
watch it migrate through the mouse and
what you see is that by about two weeks
so in the panel that says 15 you can see
that the parasite has migrated up to up
to near the brain by 18 by day 21 it's
exclusively in the brain and at this
point it switches into this cyst stage
and so this is a dormant stage where
it's hiding inside neurons and it's
actually actually kind of laying there
in the brain of the mouse for the rest
of the lifetime
of the mouse and if you then want to ask
kind of what is it doing in the brain of
like why the brain you're gonna get
eaten anyway if it is so says the
lifecycle right does it matter that the
parasite hides in the brain of its host
and so in a mouse we can ask something
like well what is the change in response
when this mouse ends up with this
parasite to the smell of cat or a cat
itself and so what we have is that these
mice that are actually infected with
this parasite they do a few things they
move more so they're just kind of like
are hyperactive they run around a bit
more they spend more time closer to the
cat urine they freeze less so rodents is
a defensive feel responsible freeze it's
part of like being a nocturnal prey
animal you just freeze and hope that the
thing doesn't see you it's like false
line of logic in Jurassic Park and
you're knows what I'm talking about
and then so or you can they also make
more exploratory bouts near the cat and
so what this means though is that these
infected mice are spending time closer
to the cat whereas previously they were
afraid of the cat
but here's I think where it gets really
interesting which is to say you don't
have access to we don't have scientists
as anyone we don't have access to the
kind of inner subjective world of the
Maya Mouse right like if we rotate if we
wanted to ask a person well are you less
afraid or are you attracted to this cat
now the person could fill out a little
questionnaire you could ask them you
could use language but you don't have
that type of access to a mouse and all
you know is that the mouse used to spend
time away from the cat and now it spends
time close to the cat but it's equally
plausible just given this behavior that
they've either become less afraid or
they're maybe they're attracted to the
cat and how do you tease apart these two
things because as a as like a
neuroscientist it's actually very
interesting there's a big difference in
the brain between when something is
afraid of something and when something
is attracted to something so what we
have here is actually kind of small
caveat that I wanted to introduce so on
the on your on your guy's left is a
video this is what the actual
experiments look
like this is what we do if we take a
mouse we put it in a rectangular chamber
and it kind of just runs around and at
one end so the top end you'll have the
cat the cat smell and a computer and
these infrared cameras will track the
mouse and then at the end it spits out
these these kind of heat maps of where
the animal spent all of its time and so
what you see is that on your right those
mice each column is a mouse ISM each
column is a mouse running through this
little really easy maze for a certain
amount of time and what what you see is
that there's this wide variation between
the mice so sometimes on their left for
example they're incredibly afraid they
spend no time near the cat sometimes on
the very very right you notice that some
of these animals actually maybe spend
about half the time actually start to
prefer the area the the part of the
arena that's closest to the cat and the
question is is infection is having this
parasite causing any of this and if you
look underneath each of the columns
you'll see either gray or red red are
the infected animals so what this means
is that if you look over to the right
the kind of like right half just divided
it visually in half you can see that
most of those animals are the infected
animals most of those animals that like
the cat the most are the ones that have
the parasite and really though what we
want to be able to do is say well how do
we tease apart whether or not these
animals these ones that spend time close
to the cat or whether or not they're
less afraid or they're neither more
attractive and so one way we can do this
is we can look in their brains right so
they can't self-report but we can we can
do a lot to learn the exact state of the
brain of the mouse so here's one example
of what happens in the brain of a mouse
of a rodent that's exposed to a cat so
when a rodents exposed to a cat they're
afraid and then they run away and then
if you look at patterns of neural
activity in their brain you actually see
that so basically what this is is a
think of it like a pathway to Ulta
behavior and what happens is that
there's a cat odor the animal smell
something there are neurons in the
olfactory bulb that respond specifically
to the smell of that cat and then this
information gets kind of pushed
downstream to other different brain
regions the amygdala and the
hypothalamus that ultimately end up
outputting fear behavior now this looks
different in kind from a male rodent
that's exposed to an estrus female
rodent a female in heat and so what this
is is sexual attraction and when you do
that you have again neural activity
coursing through the brain that's almost
like a reflexive kind of response and
you end up the behaviors different you
end up with attraction and there are
different pathways different circuits
and how this kind of helps is then we
can ask the following question so we now
have the infected Mouse it's attracted
to the cat and we can kind of choose
between two hypotheses one if it's
really attracted to the animal we would
expect the brain to be similar in its
activity to when you expose a male to a
female if it's afraid but maybe just
less afraid you might expect similar
activity to when we kind of expose the
rat to the cat but maybe just less so or
something like that that's not how the
brain works but something and then so
what we get is some kind of little
column a little column B so we actually
do have the fear response when these
infected animals are exposed to a cat
but we actually do see activity that's
commensurate in the other kind of
regions and the other pathways similar
to it was as if so here's another way of
stating that it was as if for certain
regions of the brain that respond
exclusively to sexually attractive
stimuli to attraction to female rats
it was as if when these animals were
exposed to a cat that they actually were
seeing they're kind of responding to
this this cat instead of a female rat so
that's kind of interesting we're maybe
saying that okay well we have figured
out
how it is that we're gonna tease apart
these two things so a lot of my other
work involved figuring out how we're
gonna track the parasite how we're gonna
find the individual parasite itself so
as I showed you this is how you find it
if you want to find the parasite itself
there's another way you can do this
though you can actually instead of find
the parasite you can find the places in
the brain that the parasite has gone
places in the brain the neurons the
individual neurons that the parasite has
infected so this is going to be a really
quick primer on how this works but I
promise I'm going to show you in like
two slides and like a beautiful 3d model
of a brain that you get to like zoom
through and I promise if you don't
listen now you're gonna be like oh I
should have listened three slides ago
because you know it's just green and
you're not gonna and you need to know
what it means so basically to to figure
out where the parasite goes one way to
do this is to you can genetically modify
the parasite and genetically modify the
mouse and what you do is you kind of
build in a coincidence detector so what
happens is the mouse itself is
genetically modified every every 90
million times every single neuron is
genetically modified to have a gene that
produces a green produces green but it's
turned off kind of think of it as like a
light switch that gets turned off and
then you can genetically modify the
parasite to be able to come in and
actually kind of flip this switch and
what happens is that only when the
parasite is present will that neuron
that individual neuron turn fluorescent
and green and beautiful so what this
means is that you can take the mouse and
then take its brain and then look at
slide slices of its brain and actually
find two exquisite pinpoint detail to
the individual neuron where all the
green cells are so this is the moment I
previously referenced so what this is is
you can take those 3ds 2d slices and
reconstruct it back into a
three-dimensional kind of map of every
single infected neuron in a mouse brain
so this is the first time this was ever
done and I was showing this to people
that have studied taco for a very very
long time and it was universally
surprised
Universal surprise and the reason is it
doesn't look like it goes anywhere in
particular
it doesn't look like it goes to one
particular region if I look between all
the different mice all the different
mice have completely different patterns
of this of this behavior but remember
this is actually kind of perfect in some
way in the sense that it kind of maps on
to the behavior that I that I showed
that it was quite variable so the
behavior not everything there were some
animals that had it that had the
parasite that were not afraid to the cat
there were some that had the parasite
that were became less afraid of the cat
so there's a wide range of behavioral
change and the fact that this parasite
kind of goes everywhere it's actually
really good for that type of for that
type of data because what it means is
that maybe what's happening this
parasite is randomly distributing
throughout the brain of a toast it gets
into the host and randomly jumps around
and that if and only if it ends up in a
brain region or if and only if it ends
up in one place then maybe the animal
becomes less afraid so skip that so the
next question would be like what is it
doing when it gets there and there's
some really good evidence that actually
it has the capability so this iPod kind
of almost almost like philosophically
interesting in the sense that there's
this tiny parasite single-celled
parasite but it has a gene in it that is
a perfect copy of the mammalian gene
that makes neurotransmitter the
neurotransmitter sorry it doesn't make
the neurotransmitter but it makes the
step right before the neurotransmitter
to make dopamine so the idea is that
somewhere in this cascade in a mammalian
brain in a brain and all of our brains
right now this is how this this cascade
these arrows are happening and the
parasite itself has evolved a way to
kind of get into that and alter
neurotransmitter levels and it it's
plausible that that's actually how it's
doing it it's it's kind of like
inspiring its manipulations in the brain
so this is just a show so that remember
that video I showed you now it's to
scale so this here is the scale between
a mouse and a human so that's the video
right there it's still it's playing and
so if you can imagine how many infected
neurons you saw there in the mouse you
can now imagine blow that up into a
human level how many neurons might be
infected in every
single infected human so one of the
interesting things is now we get to like
what we're really interested in right
what is talks of doing in the human
brain and I think there's this really
funny so I don't know who came into this
knowing what about this parasite but
there's this really funny thing where I
think as kind of like a culture and even
scientists are guilty of this but we
basically take something we don't
understand and we take something that we
don't know how it works and we use the
thing we don't know how it works to
explain the thing that we don't
understand and so what happened was
people are like oh hey there's this
parasite it's in the brain of all these
like billions of people that's the thing
we don't know how it works and then it's
like oh well there's there all these
mental illnesses out there that we don't
really understand maybe maybe they're
related and you can do this to a certain
extent like this is actually really it's
a good theory it's a good basis for
starting science but you can't
necessarily believe everything you hear
so the first thing you people may have
heard of this there are a few there a
few articles so in the Atlantic this is
our house your cat is making you crazy
this over here is from the the like some
major Russian news thing this was
actually their translated version of my
that paper that I showed which I
actually really left the title because I
think if with two apostrophes it's both
like grammatically and possibly
scientifically totally accurate but
there's this thing that happens which is
the parasite has been the taco has been
linked and found in people and links to
obsessive compulsive disorder migraines
depression schizophrenia getting into
car accidents being promiscuous being
neurotic and the thing that's happening
is you can imagine something similar
with say 10 years ago people discovered
that we had a third kidney and a third
of the world sorry the third of the
world had a had a kidney at a third
kidney just sitting in there doing
nothing doing absolutely nothing totally
innocuous but spread all around the
world and then you say okay well this
third kidney we don't really know what
it does but hey they're these mental
illnesses maybe and we don't really know
what they are
maybe we can link that to and then
spread around the world there's a bunch
of different like towns and cities and
countries and hospitals and you take
like 50 people every once in a while
that have that third kidney and you ask
well here fill out this personality
trait this list of all these personality
traits and then every once in a while
somewhere in the world a few times
you're going to get a positive
Association you're gonna get someone
saying hey look I figured out that the
third kidneys associated with being in
car accidents hey look I figured out
that this third kidney is being
associated with being promiscuous and
the thing is that that's not you can't
you just can't do that
and yeah that's just true you just can't
do that
so one thing though let's put a let's
put a different thresholds so let's not
say that it's okay one or two studies
let's say it's actually many we're gonna
put a threshold of like 50 studies and
so what happens is the only one that
survives that kind of like severe cut is
this linked to schizophrenia and I
actually find this to be the most
interesting and kind of part of the
reason I started studying this to begin
with was this idea that maybe this
parasite is actually linked to
schizophrenia so it's been it's been
replicated around the world many many
times and so if you look at actually the
risk factors it's at the top or the
genetic risk factors I think
schizophrenic mother-father etc but they
have the environmental ones it's the
third highest environmental risk factor
for schizophrenia so culture I want to
be a lawyer and a doctor because a woman
can do anything
2:24 Ellen I have graduated from Harvard
Medical and Yale Law Your Honor I'd like
to request a continuance so I can go
deliver a baby I love babies I'm a
little burned out so sometimes don't
shoot me I have a glass of wine with
Buster here he's a real comfort I might
even get a second cap
[Music]
if you notice there she throws out her
entirely useless Yale diploma unless do
you think that I'm pulling the curtain
over your your there's no way this could
possibly happen others alright so lest
you still don't believe me we're gonna
take a small detour inside oh hello and
welcome to another edition of micro
micro today my special guest is the one
and only dr. house dr. Patrick house how
are you thank you love your name I love
your hair love the best our topic is my
neighbor Doris who is a cat lady I can
tell you this if there she's a lay down
with approximately 20 cats and I've been
wondering is she insane because she has
20 cats or have the cat somehow got
together as group and conspired to make
Doris nuts
with me that just happens to be exactly
what I study this is gonna be a very big
show we're gonna get to the truth by
doing the only thing that makes any
sense at all we're going to get very
very very very very very small won't you
join us I promise it'll be an adventure
this is the pilot for a TV show that
never got box much like I always have
I believe Prentiss under a super smart
expert and allow him or her to abuse me
all in the selfish pursuit of feeding my
endless insatiable curiosity and like
all famous explorers I have but one Gulf
to boldly go where no tiny cheaply
animated man has gone before
[Applause]
is this your standard uniform when
you're doing science safety I see so
you're bringing the best back sweet
bleedin Jesus do you know what that is
I assume you're pointing to what can
only be turn yeah you know that smells
exactly how it looks I think we need to
go in into what in into the turn you
don't want me to drive into the turret
when a walk yeah I think we have to
rough it all right for the record half
of turd mountain here is nothing but
water and gut bacteria give or take a
few fatty acids and unabsorbed
electrolytes I don't want to be rude but
how are we best going to deal with this
particular turd
we can enter through this mining shaft
here dear God the glory days crawling
through sewers with strangers what else
you got something amazing is about to
happen you know I'm all a-tingle there
just look look look look do you see that
that's a cat's ass hole isn't it that
it's a cat's ass hole you've brought me
here inside of this turd to look up at a
cat's ass hole why because that's where
we're going yeah no yeah no yes no let's
go take my hand Mike you know what I
will hold you're in yeah give me give me
the other one too okay I guess that
could have been a well much worse really
where are we the rectum the anus yeah
where's the edge of Danis I get confused
where's the rectum in relation to the
anus ha that's right behind you I like
it in here
it's very pleasant Luke I'm your father
it sounds fantastic in a cat's ass I'll
be honest with you it doesn't smell good
all right since I have the birds I think
maybe you should hop on my back dude I
mean how much weirder does it get we're
already in a cat's ass now you want me
on yours I'm saying we're already in a
cat's ass so all right turn around don't
make any sudden moves you load sixteen
tons whoa be very quiet
do you see what that is I see everything
and yet I know what nothing is this is a
Toxoplasma gondii eye they're having sex
right now in this cat intestine
holy crap it's studio 54 it's the only
place in the world that they can
sexually reproduce this is a love hotel
for this parasite so you brought me up a
cat's rectum through its anus into its
GI tract to watch to the microscopic
pieces of bacteria get it on I brought
you here for that exact reason we just
need to grab one all right so a couple
quick questions hey what does this have
to do with my neighbor Doris and to why
do I care you have a marker of course I
do
so the parasite can only reproduce in
the GI tract right here right now where
we are of the cat but it has to get from
one cat to another cat so how does it do
that I don't know some sort of fecal
delivery system perhaps exactly so
basically the the feces comes like a
school bus and picks up all the children
doctor what is that the bus is here
right now that's not a bus that's a
ground bus I don't want to get on the
brown bus might get out I'm gonna go
Your Honor I don't wish to get on the $5
on the bus
[Applause]
well here we are on the bus it's good
bus eventually dr. Patrick would go on
to connect all the turd dots for me but
who's got time for that the sizzle reel
[Music]
doctor what's happened where are we I
told you we'd be back you don't
recognize it well yeah that that's my
truck that's your truck it looks like
you got a ticket look at that look at
that man okay so you guys are all
experts now Canyon kid did you spot the
one mistake that was not a mistake it's
not a bacteria it's a protozoan I
thought I uh that's okay so there's
another I hadn't like a tangential
intellectual pursuit as I was studying
all this and I want to talk about that
for a bit and which is related to my
current work as well and so I have this
kind of start I want to start with
something like a a thought experiment
which is could you 10,000 years ago stub
your toe do you think that for people
that stub their toe 10,000 years ago
they felt pain in the same way that we
thought that we would feel pain if we
still guard - do you think that people
10,000 years ago could break their arms
do you think that when they did so that
it was a similar way in which we now can
break our arms there's some there's some
physical property of bones that makes it
such that when they break they break in
the same way um so now sad could people
10,000 years ago be sad could people
10,000 years ago have depression so what
about what about something maybe a
little bit more complicated what about
something like cancer so do people
10,000 years ago have cancer yes or no
so there are evidence of people that
they found bodies that young children
that had bone cancer so we know that
cancer rate that there were there was
cancer but various different kind of
environmental contingencies about cancer
we didn't have radiation or x-rays or
tobacco or we didn't live long enough
sometimes back then right so so there
was cancer but there is
a smaller rate there's a lower rate so
what about something like an Alzheimer's
is there Alzheimer's 10,000 years ago
it's kind of late well okay like maybe
probably the people would have gotten it
if they had lived long enough but life
expectancy was only thirty so to say
that there was yes or no with this cut
type of difficult question was there was
there not this mental illness ten
thousand years ago is to ask is it that
they had a propensity for it or is it
so now schizophrenia with their
schizophrenia 10,000 years ago and so
the interesting question to me is is
something like schizophrenia this
disease has mental illness now that we
know so well now is it more like
breaking a bone in a sense that when the
brain breaks it breaks in a very
stereotypes in specific way it's like
the physical properties of the brain
that when they break they break the same
way or is it something more like cancer
where it's kind of the environmental
conditions don't quite they weren't
quite there they had it but there wasn't
the the there was a propensity but it
just kind of never came out and so
people have thought about this in terms
of the history of schizophrenia that's
the thing I'm most interested in part of
a part of why I studied this parasite is
it's one of the most tractable ways of
studying a schizophrenia disease model
and so when people are thinking about
this history of this of this illness you
can ask something like well when was the
first diagnosis and the first diagnosis
was in the 1880s and people have thought
you know what actually what would
happened was sometimes that was the
century when people first started living
in cities and if you if you remember
from the slide about the risk factors
for schizophrenia number one is being an
immigrant immigrants often go to cities
number two is being raised in an urban
environment
number four is being born there sorry is
living in an urban environment so
there's a link somewhere between cities
in schizophrenia and so people have
thought well maybe maybe this explains
why nobody was schizophrenic before
there were cities that had more than a
million people so these are all the
cities that had more than million to
people more than a million people in
their population but London Shanghai and
1800 were the first to sustain that so I
want to go somewhere different though
and I want to talk about well what can
we do what can we ask about this history
of this mental illness in terms of art
so there's this man Louis Wayne he was a
turn-of-the-century or
turn of 19th century so late 18-hundreds
early 1900s and he used to draw our cats
and he seemed so famous that he had like
a louis wine cat was a thing that people
new people new have the lewis wayne cat
you could buy postcards and so he was
the president of national cat society he
drew his still lifes from the cats that
he owned and he would live with up to 40
and he went schizophrenic and so there's
something really neat about an artist I
mean sorry no I entirely take that back
so we saw his art and we have his art
and we can see his art change as he
develops his mentalness so I'll just let
dart talk so there's something a little
weird that the cat on your left the one
with the green eyes he's like a little
suspicious he's not a cat that's like
everything's okay so here we have I love
the title of this actually this fire the
mind agitates the atmosphere it's the
title of this piece and then it starts
to get a little otter the blur the
blurred lines between self and on self
in inside subjective world outside
worlds you know it starts to blur a
little bit he starts to get a little
more fractal kind of odd maybe a little
bit otter and so this is the point I
think where if you're his friend
and he used to do this and now he's
doing this you're just like do you want
to go for a tea see what I like talk and
so it continues and it deteriorates and
it gets it gets really really abstract
and so there's this idea of can we take
something like art can we take something
that guard as a narrative can we take a
sequence of things that people have
drawn and produced and actually think
about it in the same way that we use to
think about diagnosing mental illness
and the only reason I say that is
because if you go into a hospital now
and you you are diagnosed with
schizophrenia not with a blood test or a
brain scan there's no EMR it's a
behavioral checklist and the question is
can we use art to go back in time and
analyze and say maybe schizophrenic drew
a certain type of art let's say could we
then go back in the history of art and
find all the schizophrenic sand then say
okay yes there was schizophrenia that's
a very like first past crew
version of this but even if you don't
buy that which like any most art critics
would just throw their glass at me so
this is Agatha Christie Agatha Christie
wrote about 82 novels she had
Alzheimer's she developed Alzheimer's
and you can track over time the
complexity the grammatical complexity
the sentence structure complexity the
use of indeterminate phrases repeated
phrases and determinate words and show
that around the time she had Alzheimer's
you could see a decrease in the
complexity of a work what does that mean
we don't know
this is Sylvia Platt there's a study a
decade ago looking at poets who had
committed suicide and poets that had not
committed suicide and they compared the
entire output the entire written output
of both of their most of those people's
works and they were looking for words
that might predict or predispose people
that poets that had eventually committed
suicide and they were looking for things
like melancholy or death or sadness or
dark but what it turned out to be was
that the most common were used by the
pseudopods that ultimately committed
suicide was I and all it is is this
behavior is this indicative this was
followed up people went into tracked and
recorded patients as they entered a
hospital that later got diagnosed with
depression and found that they to use
more self-referent words ¨i etc and so I
was investigating this for a while and I
was like how can we determine how can we
prove that schizophrenia used to be a
thing and then I realized that I only
know one thing and the thing I know is
this parasite so maybe I'll just look
for the parasite as far back as I can
find it so instead of this kind of art
can we determine behavior maybe now what
I want to do is I want to try to find
the most ancient version of the parasite
and say hey look if it has something to
do with schizophrenia now and it's in
the brains of people ten thousand years
ago maybe just maybe it has something to
do with schizophrenia back then so where
do you get the mummified parasite
so this is a small version of human
history this is the this is when we
domesticated wheat so we domesticated
wheats and when we did that we needed to
find a place to store it so this is the
long version of how cats got
domesticated when we needed to store it
we would we ancient Egyptians they built
grain silos and then they had a rat in a
mouse Pro when they had a rat in a mouse
problem that we started to welcome the
presence of cats that we domesticated
those cats so now we can ask the
following question instead of well where
are we gonna look for this parasite we
can say okay there were mummified bulls
we know cows can carry this parasite
there are mummified cats and they're
mummified people so if we can find the
parasite and we can find it in ancient
Egyptian mummies then maybe we can say
something about the history of this
disease or at the very least we can say
something about the fact that people got
this parasite so yes the idea is
ultimately to prove that just in case
you're wondering that Cleopatra is the
archetypal crazy cat lady so let's say
that we do have this parasite and it's
hanging around in cats back in the day
what one thing we can do is say well
what is the likelihood that they
actually end up with a parasite
and if you look at some of the early
medical texts went too fast
there are almost formulas these are
prescriptions so for our vg1 for the the
treatment of an open head wound
remember there are two ways to get this
parasite raw meat and cat poop so for
the treatment of an open head wound
you have to bandage him with raw meats
for the treatment of a gaping head wound
you banished with raw meats for the the
fat fur and excrements of a male cat
were used in medicine too at the bottom
feline resident will be used in a lotion
to keep the hair from turning gray so we
imagine you're in Egyptian it's like pre
germ theory at all and you go to the
doctor the doctor puts raw meat on your
open head wounds he gives you a little
bit of cat poop for your graying hair
you go home your hair is still gray
and you that you don't like wash your
hands in the Nile because you've never
washed your hands your life
and you you just eat you eat all this
and so there is a possibility that if
they had it that it would end up in
people so what I'm doing now in in in my
lab is looking for DNA of the parasite
in these ancient Egyptian mummies and
there are multiple different ways we can
get it the one there are a lot of cat
mummies in the world in it is may
surprise you but like they were at
mummifying for eight thousand years and
two examples one a few years ago a few
hundred thousand were found and also in
the 18th century there are 1800's
Britain rat backhaul ship 19 tons 19
tons 19 tons of cat mummies they had so
many that they actually sunk one of the
ships because they didn't know what to
do with it they used it for training
steam they were basically using these
mummies for carbon and ends so that
there are a lot out there and so my
project is to find this parasite in
these mummies and how do you do that
well one of a kind of recent finding is
that actually King Tut died of malaria
and so how do we know that we know King
Tut died of malaria because they found
DNA of Plasmodium falciparum which is
another parasite which is also a
protozoan that is very closely related
to Toxoplasma and so you can take tissue
samples from mummies and you can find
DNA and you can find the parasite and so
that is basically what i'm doing now so
this is the how we do its but the
important thing this is the important
thing is pictures of mummies - the
pictures of my moments and so the
smithsonian i'm collaborating with the
smithsonian on this and they have they
basically have like a raid I don't know
Raiders of the Lost Ark type like just
facility in Maryland that's just where
everything goes that's not on exhibit
and if you go there they just have a
room that just as Egypt including animal
mummies and you can see so this is a
full-size to mummify the bull so you
know it's big from here to there
full mummified bull just hanging under a
tarp here we have a cat mummy that they
pull out from the drawer and so
this is how you do it these are the cat
mommies these are one of the few
millions of cat mommies and you take
some take some tissue bring it here and
then we're gonna in progress but we will
find hopefully some of this parasite in
some of these mummies and now the third
one I promise you if you're squeamish
don't look so they have a drawer this is
the drawer I like they only had one cat
mommy and I'm talking to the archivist
the guy who's in charge of all the
Egyptian samples at the Smithsonian and
we like walk out kind of defeated he's
like sorry I thought we had more mummies
sorry but he's like well unless we're
interested in humans that would be easy
we could do that easily but if only you
were interested in humans and so he goes
back and he takes me to the human drawer
and so here we have the mummified human
heads and these have the brains actually
still inside and think I proved it by
picking it up and shaking it for me and
did you not and saying look we have we
have these brains so really we have
brain tissue we have cat tissue and we
everything is set in place we have a
site hopefully in Egypt
it's tricky there currently but they
were site hopefully in Egypt that we'll
be able to get a lot more of these but
the idea is now to to show somehow to
find the time the moment the precise
time in human history that this parasite
jumped for the first time from a cat
into a person and so I told you that
this would be talked about the evolution
of this title and hopefully now you can
understand that when I say fearless it's
not quite that when I say rats it's it's
maybe not just quite that the story has
brought in quite a bit since I first
started working on this and so if you
have I'm out of time so if you have any
questions now's the time
all right we've got time for a few
questions I saw some hands right there
on the wall thanks a lot yes yes
toxoplasmosis available well swimming in
the ocean you could it would be
astronomically unlikely so it would be
like the way that the sea otters get it
is they actually have a diet that where
they eat snails
they eat sea snails and the sea snails
are sponges they're vectors they absorb
pretty much every pathogen the ocean has
there they're literally just little
sponges you've seen a snail there's
literally sponges and so that's how they
get it I think the like likelihood of
picking it up in just by swallowing is
so so so small just talk so affect men
and women differently right so there's
this odd thing where when you study a
mind-control parasite that may or may
not cause schizophrenia you get odd
emails at times and oh really yeah yeah
that's true and so I once got an email
from a woman in Greece asking me to give
her the parasite I could i inject her
with the parasite and the reason is she
had read an article stating that it
makes you more extroverted and she said
that she had been feeling introverted
lately I'm not even kidding and so
there's this thing and then I I don't
know why but these emails tend to be
women and there's another there's a
middle-aged woman who emailed me asking
she said that she had gotten talks it
when she was 9 so if you can get talked
to when you're in your I just like a
it's a thing it's a medical thing
and she that she had had had a lifetime
of difficult relationships and divorces
was the parasite did it was that the
parasite
and there's this thing where it's like
it's like funny but it's also like
tragic in a way and I think and I think
one of what's happening here is that
people have this like there's something
terrifying about this idea that you can
be kind of controlled or manipulated in
some way it's like the basis of so many
science fiction think about it think
about any science fiction film that has
a character who is not in control of
their own behavior for something like
mysterious unknown reason there's like
there's a compelling fear there and
there's also though something very like
validating and almost like compassionate
about knowing that something is maybe an
excuse for all of your negative behavior
in the same way and so all of those
studies though the people these these
emails that I get from people are coming
from people that have read these studies
that are a single study that as I said
about the like third kidney thing it's
like a third kidney with the thing and
it's just a single study it hasn't been
repeated it was done in like 20 or 50
people in the Czech Republic or
somewhere and and you just I try to be
kind and like compassionate but I don't
believe any of those so Patrick as a
scientist is a scientist is pretty early
on in his career and who we used invoke
science fiction here for for a second
this is you know science is about
understanding the world and and you know
understanding how things work and
understanding life but this is like
undoubtedly a really weird and
interesting subject so for you in terms
of deciding what to study and also in
terms of thinking how this fits in in
terms of you know curing cancer and
other things like that
I don't know is there something you
could say about how you ended up here I
guess and and and where this yeah so I
think I think actually one of the most
interesting things about this particular
model or I can use the laser pointer
actually is that so there's a nice
almost like confluence of events here
which is that the actual life cycle of
the parasite actually requires mice and
this just happened
to be the thing that like humanity has
decided to study for a hundred years and
so a lot of times when you study mice
you're studying like depression in mics
or Alzheimer's in mice or all these
things in mice and what I like about
this there's like a purity of simplicity
that they're to the fact that this
phenomenon actually requires my so when
you're studying at you're studying the
actual phenomenon itself I kind of came
into this from a more like I I applied I
knew I wanted to study this and I just
had to figure out where was being
researched and the reason I kind of came
into it was because I just found it's
it's so unique that a parasite or a
pathogen can actually make it into the
human brain and not kill the person so
there are others there's like a tapeworm
and there's other types of parasites
that can get into the brain but they all
kill their hosts so this idea that this
thing is just kind of sitting in there
and it's maybe doing something in the
long term just kind of existentially
worried me and I like that type of worry
so this is a strange kind of self
defense let's go yeah yeah okay you have
no woman asking for my right here on the
second right now yes so we went in
through the cat but and we're now you're
going in through the mummy had at the
mom and where does that lead to another
bus yeah there's probably a different
bus like yeah down the Nile how about a
raft down the Nile that counts but ya
know the current today research projects
is fine is sequencing these mummies and
and what's what's the expected hope for
the is it are you at the point where
you've you you have so I'm thinking
about this which is okay tell us the
last page of the paper you know you're
gonna write when you twist the evidence
to
yes perfect okay so you're Gena
everyone's genome right now is degrading
so you have a TC and G and the C at the
genome is actually turning into some
it's called a you is turning into a
thing that's not even like biologically
relevant right now currently it happens
about 10,000 times a day in a single
person
yeah genome itself they look kind of
like all the DNA in each cell there's
evidence that if you didn't have all the
corrective mechanisms that are
constantly working to keep all the
repairs and every reattach everything
that your entire it would be useless in
about an hour in a person a living
person
so all of these things to kind of make a
genome stable require active living
processes and when someone dies say
5,000 years ago the day they died that
DNA starts degrading and the process by
which that happens over time we don't
know for certain but I've come up with I
think like a an easy way to describe how
difficult the process is of finding the
parasite in ancient Egyptian mummy with
it's all to creating it's mostly
bacterial there's contamination which is
which is you're looking for a needle in
a haystack
okay but that the needle has been broken
into tens of thousands of pieces okay
that's fine and the needle is made of
hay so so like so I give it like a I
don't know it's a it's a hard it's a
hard project it is if if Egypt if you
don't find the answer in Egypt is there
another best oldest's yeah so the
actually the most likely and the
Smithsonian has also given me their
samples with this which is it's actually
it's a copper light this this is like
it's less romantic it's big it's
basically fossilized catch it and it's
ten thousand years old so it's like this
in a cave in Montana and and that's
actually most likely to have the
parasite and so I have some of those as
well
so if the Egyptian mummies it's got as
like you know it's got its own merit but
we're also we kind of have a backup
which is if we're gonna find it probably
the likeliest place we're gonna find an
ancient version of this parasite is in
fossilized cat poop oh we have a lot of
questions yes
all right let's take the whoever's the
furthest back is there someone that said
you you over there so finding toxo and
autistic children and what's there to
say yeah so I can answer that in
schizophrenia and I can enter there
broadly in schizophrenia which is to say
there are different rates so let's let's
just say for a second that there there
is a relationship between
toxo and schizophrenia there are
different rates of talk so in countries
around the world so Brazil Brazilian
barbecue they have like 60% there there
are countries that have us has about 20%
so it varies wildly but the rate of
schizophrenia is exactly the same it's
about 1% in all countries so there are
people that have schizophrenia that do
not have the parasite and there are
people that have the parasite that do
not have schizophrenia probably what's
happening is an interaction between
genetics and environment like that's
just what all mental illnesses are going
to end up being and so in the case of
talk to with schizophrenia in particular
I think what's happening is probably
there are people that are maybe
predisposed to schizophrenia maybe talks
is the one thing that's pushing them
over the edge
something like that so there's an
interaction but we really don't know
enough at this point so all right Laura
from long now
as the body of an immune reaction to
toxa yes that the body absolutely does
and the body the normal competent human
body is very very good at taking care of
toxo and eliminating talks about so most
people if they have it there's no
symptoms it becomes a problem in a few
cases one in HIV so is the leading cause
of death in HIV for a while the reason I
don't know so the reason is that in the
brain there's a particular type of
immune cell that's keeping talk so down
tamping in town and in HIV that
particular cell gets taken out and so
then it becomes wild and and and so talk
so toxoplasmosis encephalitis is a thing
where the brain swells because there's
so much talk so so it's a tricky
question yes the the normal competent
human body can totally take care of
talks oh okay well perhaps just gonna
stick around there's a bunch more
questions and you're gonna answer all of
them before we allow you to leave that
right so before let me before we go just
for people that want to keep an eye on
on your work that you're doing and also
we haven't really talked about the fact
you also write for The New Yorker and
for a few other places
let's just talk real quick about where
people can find your stuff i Patrick
house.com but it's okay and that's
linked off our websites yeah yeah and
your next thing you're writing for The
New Yorker is it's on the rabies virus
it's on domesticating viruses so and
then an argument that viruses have been
domesticated when winds that one side
coming out I don't know all right we'll
find out okay
let me have a big round of applause for
Patrick
[Applause]
you
[Music]